look so pretty okay yeah no it's fine
Shh no we're not
what don't blow my cover thank you
I got it from lucky' story oh I'm so
glad you asked that because I do my hair
and oh my god I don't have any shades
the cocktails are amazing yeah I know
they're so good
Oh sister you're just saying that okay I
guess I'm distracted by a radiance allow
me to introduce myself
ah a kidnapping and murder and pot
pourri that's a great combination I must
say
it's my drink I ring by - compliments of
the lady in red
why alright thanks sister
playboy okay
I'm not very whoops what just happened
have to have diarrhea okay I think it
works I think they bought it
Oh Oliver no I don't let's talk to the
sister that goddamn you're annoyed hey
[ __ ] if then yeah Nikki oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no hi sheep lost on me
what Paul not the jazzman Oh No
I've been abducted by aliens am i tied I
think I'm titled it oh I'm free I'm free
what do they do then wait that's gross
man what I'm taking this no I can't
well [ __ ]
[ __ ] they've been spying on me I wonder
what they found out
well I guess I got escaped read me
tourists in the stake yard you are in
terminal peril I want to help come to
come to the rear pool verify you're not
shadow what okay this is the rear pool
goddamn that took me a while yeah we go
finally what the what oh damn this is
kind of cool Holly buddy
hi you made it yes I thought you were
and followed of course I'm pretty big
information for you but first get
disability precautions goddamn it let me
just hold still
he's gonna pull her aside when you are
ready you should sit down baguette
there's a trauma cars over there okay
sit down to the intends near side
listen carefully this resort it's all
think it's soft there we are all
characters enough see you later
it's taken me decades but I've
discovered the way out of your hate
random mechanical work as I seen him
with Luke yet I will will lead you to
freedom I knew he was like this
perpetrator the natives use it for
hunting it was
Thanks Godspeed all alike
Godspeed dad to kill him Peggy ma'am
where is that love [ __ ] how dare is oh
it's coming right for me what the hell
was I did I kill it I got it
alright now we need a cookie oh how
convenient alright that's what happens
piggy
this was [ __ ] hippie it's pretty hot
yeah yeah okay sure whatever
oh god what is happening now escape okay
okay are we going up this one huh okay
it's actually kind of cool I just don't
know what the [ __ ] is happening it's
like a thing my flight is go through you
this all makes to it I've seen it there
you go
incredible machine anyway stop bragging
okay what okay history right that
actually treats me
okay I'm gonna say press the S to step
away from Kyle a provision press down a
forward punch again to Hadouken your
terminal down for punch
hello again I don't get I'm glad we did
that
no no patient down ah that's [ __ ] up
man
alright here we are finally
commander Pettit no I gotcha dad is one
of my cafe come on I'm sorry I Oh
where's the but we're back here the hell
okay did we make it
you should be here you should be the one
yep there is hi curious
please have a seat we've much business
to discuss
never trust this this doesn't seem legit
and no tricks like this message it oh
why did she have to burn yeah I want I
want this to be a jazz I hope we will go
back to the jazz man it seems that my
mouse is a little bit sensitive how so
she said hillarious say they director
survived a a Clockwork Orange [ __ ]
love this this is Beethoven okay I I
think I me gal folio right hell are you
doing with that friggin arm well look at
this place I am the exterminator to
having to get it god damn it
all right what am I supposed to
exterminate shoes what is this anyway
oh god god damn it God sighs so close
oi oi let's talk two [ __ ] instead of
all good Bruges oh sorry all right
Oh No are those my are there microchips
are theirs [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know oh
I had to show you I have to show you
they sent me the Captain Crunch
now cut sorry comrade comrade Krebs and
it says the free copy of jazz bug inside
so it has the game inside isn't that
awesome I think that's so cool thanks
for saying that
I really like and there's actual cereals
it's kind of cool
can I call you gotta admit that's pretty
[ __ ] cool
all right I'm done oh so that's what I
had well what if I want to keep this I
guess I can't [ __ ] alright yeah what do
I do now for human thank you very much
you [ __ ] ass eyes I get to say is
that don't touch me alright so I'll be
making myself at home until the base
comes here let's talk to the lady what's
up girl oh my gosh
I've been waiting all night let's do it
I'm ready we gotta look oh god that's
I don't eclis near [ __ ] you don't
even oh god I thought she was gonna do
my nails that's [ __ ]
ain't nobody touch I ain't nobody I know
[ __ ] is you know what I was gonna say
okay there you go
I'll cut off your tits nice sound
effects okay there we go
you're welcome yes oh my god I thought
you never to asks mates nailed part
alright which color do you want baby I
can do all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
website yeah bet you does you dirty [ __ ]
Omega what
where I'm not done I'm not done come on
yeah you're welcome sister yeah I know
we should do it again sometime
or how about never you piece of [ __ ]
look at the floor instead all right give
me the hoppy what is this
Prometheus better than this play hmm man
they they sure had swag back in the day
man
look at that [ __ ] what's with the Oscar
laters man freaks me out
well that's a cool LP man all right Oh
Dana's every instrument in this room is
constantly moral no I want to listen all
right let's play this one that's what
I'm talking about girl now she come to
dance for me girl my friend ever never
oh nice shake your titties to the lamp
now shake your penis mother right now
what what what what nice shake your
booty for it hey you in the back no no
truck no try get off you think I blank
what I doing anything